hey what's up everyone its Nicole here
and I'm at BuzzFeed and I'm here to
answer some of your burning questions
[Music]
okay what made you decide to join the
show as a host this show summit
completely bonkers and crazy
I love bunkers and crazy is something
different something I've never even seen
before we don't even have anything like
this in the States it's a show that
actually originated in Asia and it was
such a phenomenon over there so it's
like alright let's do this and then when
I found out who the fellow panelists and
the host where I was like yeah this is
gonna be fun are the responses to the
judges pre-decided or are they allowed
to say whatever they want we could say
whatever the full lip we want we're
totally not pre-decided because we have
no idea what we're about to see we're
not involved behind the scenes or in any
way are allowed to communicate in any
way with the contestants or their
entourage that actually fully masked and
covered and all black at all times so
when we see them it's always for the
first time actually when they come
onstage are the singers coached or
trained at all through the show or is
everything they do their own talent
everything they do is their own talent
they even choose their own songs it's
part of the objective of the show to be
able to let the contestants show a whole
nother side of themselves to the world
that we're not used to seeing right it
just like comes back and hits me in the
head okay how long does a round of sing
offs take how many episodes of the show
were taped in one day so a round of sing
offs take about a half a day to a full
day to shoot and there were a few days
that we had to tape double so we would
start really early in the morning and
work till really late at night do you
ever get to speak to the contestants
one-on-one backstage absolutely not that
would defeat the purpose we have no
contact with the contestants or their
entourage everything is on absolute
lockdown because it's very secret secret
okay which guest judge is the best
guesser not me okay everybody brings
something different to the panel
I think Jenny is the best gas syrup
because it's kind of her job to
interview people she has her own radio
show and she's just really good with
that stuff where I'm not what is the
rehearsal process like for the
contestants I have no idea because I'm
not a part of that process but next
question what happens if someone's masks
were to fall off in the middle of a
performance we'd probably get really
high ratings extra extra ratings of I
have no idea how the masks are I think
every mask is obviously really different
but it seems like it takes hours for
them when we're revealing we're like
take it
[Applause]
ten minutes go by we're like take it off
not ready when lord knows they're
sweating under there god bless them so
I'd be like not yeah I got a touch me up
then we got to put it like real cute
right here and then uh I'll pretend with
the struggle that the struggle is real
okay this is the last question we save
the best for last
it's the hottest question how important
are the clues and the video packages
versus what they say to the judges I
think that every clue is important
because we have no idea you you all have
to understand that at home you have
Google but this is the first time that
we're receiving any information through
these clue packages or seeing the
contestants so we don't get the luxury
of Google I think it's more important
the clues whenever we get to here direct
answers from the contestants or when
they bring out their physical clues I
think sometimes in the packages they're
clues but sometimes I think they do it
to throw us off all right BuzzFeed thank
you so much that was so much fun make
sure to tune in to the messenger see you
later
[Music]